NOW, THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY FROM
NEW YORK.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT
THAT WILL TAKE THE NEXT TEN
HOURS TO GIVE YOU ALL THE NEWS
WE HAVE, WE ARE TRYING TO BREAK
IT DOWN AS BEST WE CAN.
WE HAVE TWO BREAKING NEWS
STORIES WE ARE TRACKING TONIGHT,
MOMENTS AGO, WE RECEIVED
DEFINITIVE EVIDENCE THAT THE
CORRUPT, COMPROMISED CONGENITAL
LIAR, THAT GUY THAT I’VE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT, ADAM SCHIFF,
HE HAS WILLFULLY BEEN DECEIVING
YOU, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
YEARS.
TRANSCRIPTS HE’S BEEN HIDING
FROM THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE’S
WITCH HUNT INTO RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE HAVE FINALLY BEEN
RELEASED, THANKS TO THE DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR, DOCUMENTS
REVEALING BOMBSHELL NO
INFORMATION ON WHAT BARACK OBAMA
KNEW ABOUT DEEP STATE SPYING.
BREAKING TONIGHT, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR HAVE
RIGHTLY DROPPED ALL CHARGES
AGAINST LIEUTENANT GENERAL
MICHAEL FLYNN, THAT MEANS THE
FOUR YOUR NIGHTMARE WILL BE OVER
AND ONLY IF THE PRESIDING JUDGE
AGREES WITH THE DOJ’S MOTION.
FLYNN WAS WE’VE TOLD YOU FOR
YEARS AND INNOCENT MAN, HE’S AN
HONORABLE MAN.
A 33 YEAR VETERAN WHO SERVED HIS
COUNTRY WITH DISTINCTION BUT
BECAUSE OF HIS SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE LIKE THE
PRESIDENT AND MANY OTHER PEOPLE
WERE SUBJECTED TO YEARS OF TOTAL
BY A CORRUPT GROUP OF DIRTY COPS
TO QUOTE JOE DIGENOVA.
THE FIRST TIME HE SET IT ON THE
SHOW -- THAT’S NOT HOW WE
BELIEVE COPS ACT.
IT WAS ONLY 1%, NOT THE RANK AND
FILE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO GENERAL FLYNN
IS JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
WE’RE GOING TO LAY OUT A
COMPREHENSIVE TIMELINE OF THIS
CORRUPTION, WE WILL DETAIL THE
VERY REAL CRIMES THAT WE BELIEVE
WERE COMMITTED BY THESE FEW
HIGH-RANKING BAD ACTORS, WE’LL
CALL OUT WHAT IS THE MEDIA MOB,
THE ACTING CHEERLEADERS FOR
GOVERNMENT MALFEASANCE.
THERE WERE GOING AFTER PHONY
STORIES LIKE RUSSIA COLLUSION
AND UKRAINE QUID PRO QUO,
IGNORING THE DIRTY DOSSIER,
DISINFORMATION FROM THE GET-GO.
THEY IGNORED YOU’RE NOT GETTING
THE MILLION UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR, PAY MY INEXPERIENCED
SON MILLIONS JUST TO GO AFTER
DONALD TRUMP.
IT HAS BEEN A TWO TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOW
SPEAKING OUT, WE HAVE PART OF
THE INTERVIEW HE GAVE EARLIER
TONIGHT.
FLYNN’S ATTORNEY SIDNEY HOWELL,
THE GREAT ONE MARK LEVIN WILL
WEIGH IN AND THANK GOD SHE IS
FREE, WE WILL HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH SHELLEY LUTHER,
THE SALON OWNER THAT WAS TOLD
YOU APOLOGIZE TO THE GOVERNMENT
OR YOU’RE GOING TO JAIL.
A FAR LEFT WING JUDGE PUT HER
BEHIND BARS, SLAPPED HER WITH A
$7,000 FINE BECAUSE SHE WANTED
HER EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO FEED
THEIR KIDS AND SHE REFUSED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR TRYING TO FEED HER
CHILDREN AND THOSE WHO WORK FOR
HER -- SHE’S A HERO FOR STANDING
UP TO THAT JUDGE.
WE’VE GOT TO ADDRESS WHAT IS THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS GREAT
REPUBLIC.
OUR CONSTITUTION, LIBERTY, EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
PEOPLE WHO ABUSE POWER, PEOPLE
WHO ARE CORRUPT.
THE POWERFUL USE OF INTELLIGENCE
MISUSED, PEOPLE WITH AGENDAS.
WHAT WAS AN ATTEMPT AT STOPPING
DONALD TRUMP FROM BEING
PRESIDENT AND UNDOING AN
ELECTION.
THEY DIDN’T LIKE THE CHOICE OF
VIEW, WE THE PEOPLE SO THEY DID
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER, A LOT
OF CORRUPT THINGS AND ILLEGAL
THINGS TO TAKE DONALD TRUMP
DOWN.
THEY TRIED EVER SINCE HE WAS
ELECTED AND EVEN BEFORE HE WAS
ELECTED.
SHORTLY AFTER THE DOJ
ANNOUNCEMENT, LIEUTENANT GENERAL
FLYNN TWEETED OUT THIS VIDEO OF
HIS GRANDSON, IT REMINDS US THAT
THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE AND THERE
IS HOPE AND SOMETIMES WITH GOOD
PEOPLE IN POWER, JUSTICE CAN AND
WILL PREVAIL, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
>> Sean: MAYBE HE CAN TEACH
JOE BIDEN HOW TO SAY THINGS, HE
GOT IT RIGHT.
IT LOOKS LIKE GENERAL FLYNN’S
GRANDSON UNDERSTANDS THE CORE
AMERICAN PRINCIPLE BETTER THAN
SOME OF THESE CORRUPT BAD ACTORS
WHO TRY TO PERSECUTE HIS
GRANDFATHER.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT HOW WE GOT
HERE.
START IN EARLY JANUARY 2017
BEFORE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS EVEN
SWORN INTO OFFICE.
THE FBI DETERMINED FLYNN HAD
DONE NOTHING WRONG.
COMEY’S CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE INVESTIGATION FOUND NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THANKS TO A RECENT DOCUMENT
DISCOVERY WE LEARNED THAT BY
JANUARY OF 2017 THERE WAS NO
DEROGATORY MATERIAL ON FLYNN IN
THE FBI’S FILE, ZERO IN THE
DEFENSE INTEL AGENCY FILES, ZERO
DEROGATORY MATERIAL AS IT
RELATES TO MATERIAL IN THE CIA
FILES AND WE KNOW THAT BY
JANUARY 4TH, THE CASE AGAINST
FLYNN WAS SUPPOSED TO BE CLOSED.
THAT IS UNTIL THE FBI LEADERSHIP
ON THE INFAMOUS SEVENTH FLOOR
GOT INVOLVED.
THAT SAME DAY THAT PETER STRZOK
COMPLETED DON’T CLOSE OUT THE
CASE, INCOMES JIM COMEY.
THE FOURTH DAY INTO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, ASKED WHAT IS
OUR GOAL?
TRUTH, ADMISSION OR TO GET TO
GENERAL FLYNN TO LIE SO THAT
THEN WE CAN PROSECUTE HIM AND
GET HIM FIRED OR GET HIM FIRED?
THOSE WORDS SHOULD NEVER COME
OUT OF ANYBODY IN THE FBI, EVER.
THE GOAL SHOULD BE JUSTICE AND
THE TRUTH ALWAYS, THAT’S NOT A
QUESTION THAT HE SHOULD HAVE
EVER ASKED.
THE FACT THAT HE ASKED IT AND
GOT ANSWERS IS SCARY.
THAT QUOTE QUITE LITERALLY IS
THE DEFINITION OF A PERJURY
TRAP.
IN JIM COMEY’S FBI, IT WAS ALL
MEANS TO AN END, JANUARY 24TH,
MR. HIGHER LOYALTY SUPER PATRIOT
HIMSELF JIM COMEY DIRECTED HIS
AGENTS TO AMBUSH GENERAL FLYNN
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND AS HE
BRAGGED ABOUT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE CHAOS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
SOMETHING HE WOULDN’T DO IN THE
OBAMA OR BUSH ADMINISTRATION’S
OR GET AWAY WITH AND PUSH ASIDE
ALL DUE PROCESS WHICH WOULD BE
GOING THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE
GENERAL COUNSEL.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE’S A
DISREPUTABLE RIGHT-HAND MAN, HE
TOLD FLYNN YOU DON’T NEED A
LAWYER, THAT WAS A LIE TOO.
COMEY SENT THE MEN.
LIKE THE IDIOTIC, POMPOUS THAT
JIM COMEY BRAGGED ABOUT, HE
BRAGGED ABOUT THE WHOLE DIRTY
TRICK ON CAMERA.
THINK ABOUT THIS, DOES THIS
SOUND LIKE A GUY THAT HAS A
HIGHER LOYALTY TO TRUTH, HONOR,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES?
BECAUSE TO ME, HE IS THE DIRTY
COP THAT JOSEPH DiGENOVA
WARNED US ABOUT.
>> YOU LOOK AT THIS WHITE HOUSE
NOW AND IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE TWO
FBI AGENTS ENDING UP IN THE SAME
ROOM, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I SENT THEM.
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN’T
HAVE DONE OR GOTTEN AWAY WITH IN
A MORE ORGANIZED INVESTIGATION,
A MORE ORGANIZED ADMINISTRATION,
IN BOTH OF THOSE ADMINISTRATION
THERE WAS PROCESS.
SO IF THE FBI WANTED TO SEND
AGENTS INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
ITSELF TO INTERVIEW A SENIOR
OFFICIAL, YOU WOULD WORK THROUGH
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL AND
APPROVAL AND IT WOULD BE THERE
AND I THOUGHT IT’S EARLY ENOUGH,
LET’S JUST SEND A COUPLE GUYS
OVER.
>> Sean: YOU THINK THAT’S
FUNNY?
REALLY?
33 VETERAN OF THIS COUNTRY, YOU
DON’T NEED A LAWYER, YOU’RE
SENDING THEM IN, YOU’RE SETTING
HIM UP, YOU’RE DOING THINGS HE
WOULDN’T DO TO ANYBODY ELSE,
WOW.
JIM COMEY WAS USING THE LOGAN
ACT -- 1799 LAW THAT NOBODY HAS
EVER BEEN PROSECUTED UNDER, EVER
TO SQUEEZE LIEUTENANT GENERAL
FLYNN.
NOBODY EVER FOUND GUILTY OF
VIOLATING THAT OBSCURE LAW SINCE
1799 AND GET THIS, THE AGENTS
THAT CONDUCTED THE AMBUSH, THEY
DIDN’T THINK THAT FLYNN WAS
LYING.
WE DON’T HAVE THE ORIGINAL NOTES
THAT STRZOK AND PAIGE WERE
TALKING ABOUT ALTERING LATER ON
BECAUSE IN SEARCH OF A CRIME YOU
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE STRZOK AND PAGE
DOING THE BIDDING, THEY MADE
SIGNIFICANT REVISIONS TO THE
ORIGINAL 302, THEY CHANGED THE
INTERVIEW NOTES.
THEY SET HIM UP AGAIN.
THEY INVENTED THE PERJURY TRAP,
THAT’S BY SAYING YOU DON’T NEED
A LAWYER.
WHAT DOES OUR GOAL HERE, DO WE
WANT HIM TO LIE OR SET HIM UP SO
HE GETS PROSECUTED?
ALL THE WHILE COMEY AND McCABE
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN, THEY
THEMSELVES PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
THE ISA COURT.
DESPITE KNOWING FULL WELL THAT
HILLARY’S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER, EVEN THE NEW YORK
TOILET PAPER TIMES FIGURED OUT
WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SHE PAID FOR RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE AND THEY USED IT AS
THE BASIS FOR THE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATIONS.
WE LEARNED AN AWFUL LOT IN THE
PAPERS ABOUT THAT.
THAT WAS THE TAKE AWAY OF
CARTER PAGE’S CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
IN JUNE OF 2017 WELL INTO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THEY
SIGNED OFF ON THE FOURTH PFIZER
RENEWAL.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THEY KNEW
MONTHS EARLIER THAT IT WAS
USELESS, THEY HAD DEBUNKED IT,
THEY KNEW IT WASN’T TRUE.
THEY KNEW THE SUB SOURCE AFTER
THREE INTERVIEWS HAD SAID THAT’S
NOT ACCURATE.
AUGUST 2ND 2017, YOU HAD THE
ACTING AG ROD ROSENSTEIN
PROVIDING ROBERT MUELLER WITH A
LETTER DETAILING THE SCOPE OF
THE INVESTIGATION.
THAT CONSISTED OF A FEW DOZEN
BASELESS CHARGES AND A FEW
ALLEGATIONS TOTALLY UNRELATED TO
POLLUTION.
THE ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
GENERAL FLYNN HAD PREVIOUSLY
BEEN DEBUNKED BY THE FBI IN
EARLY JANUARY, PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON A FISA COURT, THEY WERE
WARNED BEFORE THE OCTOBER 2016
FISA APPLICATION.
WE HAVE A NEWSPAPERS
ANDREW MCCABE ADMITTING -- HE
ACTUALLY SAID I DON’T KNOW IF
ANY OF ITS TRUE AND HE ALSO SAID
WITHOUT IT, THEY NEVER WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN THE PHIS APPLICATION
APPROVED.
THAT IS WHAT GUYS LIKE
ADAM SCHIFF HAVE BEEN HIDING
FROM WE THE PEOPLE ALL THIS TIME
TIME.
THE PROBE WAS A POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT, IT A HOAX, IT WAS A
CONSPIRACY AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED COUP TO
UNDO A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND TAKE HIM DOWN.
AND LIE ABOUT IT THE WHOLE WAY.
THAT’S WHY THEY TURNED THE
SCREWS ON FLYNN.
I’M LOOKING AT THE TWEETS BY
IDIOTS LIKE SCHIFF AND NADLER --
THE FBI DIDN’T THINK HE WAS
LYING.
WHEN THEY FINALLY THREATEN TO
PUT HIS SON IN JAIL AFTER HE WAS
BANKRUPT AND AFTER HE HAD TO
SELL HIS HOUSE AND HAD NO MORE
MONEY LEFT AT THAT POINT TO PAY
THE LEGAL FEES, THEY SAID THEY
HAVE TO LOCK UP THE GUY’S SON,
WHERE DO I SIGN?
LIKE THE GREAT SOLDIER HE WAS,
HE DOVE ON THE SWORD TO PROTECT
HIS FAMILY, THAT’S NOT LYING,
THAT’S PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT.
THAT IS ABUSE OF POWER, THAT IS
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT REFERRED TO
IT AS TREASON, TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE WAS TARGETED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND HE WAS
TARGETED IN ORDER TO TRY AND
TAKE DOWN A PRESIDENT AND WHAT
THEY’VE DONE IS A DISGRACE.
I HOPE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO PAY A BIG PRICE.
THEY ARE DISHONEST, CROOKED
PEOPLE, THEY ARE SCUM.
THEY ARE HUMAN SCUM, THIS SHOULD
NEVER HAVE HAPPENED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WAS A DISGRACE AND
THEY GOT CAUGHT.
VERY DISHONEST PEOPLE.
MUCH MORE, IT’S TREASON.
>> Sean: WHAT THEY DID TO
GENERAL FLYNN, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, ROGER STONE,
PAUL MANAFORT, IT WAS ALL A
MEANS TO AN END BASED ON RUSSIAN
LIES.
THEY DIDN’T CARE THAT THEY
RUINED A 33 YEAR VETERAN’S LIFE
OR HIS FAMILY’S LIFE, THESE BAD
ACTORS, THEY WANTED TO UNDO YOUR
ELECTION, YOUR, MEANING WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AT ALL COSTS.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA WERE ALL
CHEERING IT ON, WRONGLY, EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG,
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> DID FLYNN GO ROGUE WHEN HE
SPOKE TO RUSSIA?
>> THAT WOULD BE A BIGGER
SCANDAL THAN ALMOST ANYTHING
WE’VE EVER SEEN AND ANY
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
>> BREAKING NEWS, "ABC NEWS"
BRIAN ROSS IS REPORTING MICHAEL
FLYNN PROMISED FULL COOPERATION
TO THE MUELLER TEAM AND IS
PREPARED TO TESTIFY THAT AS A
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP DIRECTED
HIM TO MAKE CONTACT WITH THE
RUSSIANS, YES!
>> WE’RE GOING TO HEAR BACK TO
MICHAEL FLYNN’S GUILTY PLEA,
IT’S MADE IT A HISTORIC DAY IN
D.C.
>> THE FACT IS MICHAEL FLYNN
BETRAYED HIS COUNTRY.
>> MICHAEL FLYNN BETRAYED THE
NATION.
>> Sean: MICHAEL FLYNN DID
NOTHING WRONG, WHERE ARE THE
APOLOGIES, WHERE DOES HE GO TO
GET HIS GOOD NAME BACK, WHERE
DOES HE GO TO GET HIS HOUSE
BACK?
HOW DOES HE GET FOUR YEARS OF
HIS LIFE BACK?
THOSE IDIOTS IN THE MEDIA MOB
HAVE BEEN LYING, SMEARING,
SLANDERING, BESMIRCHING,
CHARACTER ASSASSINATING
EVERYBODY AND ANYBODY IN THEIR
PSYCHOTIC RAGE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, LIKE THEY’RE DOING
RIGHT NOW, LIKE THEY DO EVERY
DAY.
THE WASHINGTON COMPOST, THE
NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TIMES,
FAKE NEW CNN, THEY CARRIED THE
WATER FOR ALL OF THE LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES COME EVERY
HOAX, EVERY BAD ACTOR, THEY
PUBLISH EVERY DECEPTIVE LIE AND
LEAK AND THEY LIE TO PURPOSELY
MISLEAD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EVERY SECOND, EVERY MINUTE,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY TO
BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT YOU, WE
THE PEOPLE ELECTED.
NOT ONLY IS IT A DISSERVICE TO
THE CONTRARY, THEY TOO MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE, THIS IS
DANGEROUS WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
HERE.
THEY GOT AWFULLY CLOSE TO
SUCCEEDING ON A MOUNTAIN OF LIES
THAT THEY PERPETRATED TO BECAUSE
THEY ARE TOO LAZY AND TOO
CORRUPT TO SEARCH FOR REAL
TRUTH.
ALL OF THOSE SO CALLED NEWS
OUTLETS MISSED THE VEGAS ABUSE
OF POWER THEY HAVE EVER HAD IN
THEIR LIFETIME AND THEY PEDDLED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES IN THE END.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM WERE
SEARCHING FOR TRUTH AND JUSTICE,
WE WENT OUR OWN PATH WITH OUR
ENSEMBLE TEAM AND AFTER A LONG
WAIT, THIS IS THE BEGINNING,
JUSTICE IS COMING.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY SAID THE
DURUM INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATORS WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN PROSECUTIONS.
JIM COMEY, I HOPE YOU’RE WORRIED
TONIGHT.
YOUR CORRUPTION HAS BEEN LAID
BARE FOR ALL TO SEE.
I WILL SAY OUR FRIEND
JOE DIGENOVA -- MY FAMILY HAD A
LOT OF POLICE OFFICERS, MY MOM
WAS A PRISON GUARD, MY DAD WAS A
PROBATION OFFICER, THERE WERE
TWO GUYS IN MY FAMILY WHO MADE
IT TO THE FBI.
THERE WAS A REVERENCE FOR THEM
UNLIKE ANY FAMILY MEMBER.
TONIGHT, TOLD ME HE SEES HIMSELF
AS AN AMERICAN HERO BECAUSE HE
SO DELUSIONAL ON TWITTER HE’S
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE DOJ
SEEKING THE TRUTH AND DROPPING
ITS CASE AGAINST FLYNN -- THE
DOJ HAS LOST ITS WAY.
CAREER PEOPLE PLEASE STAY,
AMERICA NEEDS YOU, THE COUNTRY
IS HUNGRY FOR HONEST, COMPETENT
LEADERSHIP.
HE IS PROBABLY ASKING HIS FELLOW
DEEP STATORS TO STICK AROUND, I
DON’T THINK ANYBODY WILL BE
TAKING ANY ADVICE FROM THE
DISGRACE FIRED FBI DIRECTOR.
IT SOON, IF THERE’S EQUAL
JUSTICE, EQUAL APPLICATION, I